we're told let a and b be rational
numbers and let b be non-zero they have
to say let b be non-zero because we're
about to divide by b is a over b
rational or irrational
well let's think about they're both
rational numbers so that means that a
since it's rational can be expressed as
the ratio of two integers so i could
write a is equal to m over n and same
thing about b i could write b
as being equal to p
over q
where
where m
n
p
and q
are integers
are
integers by definition of what a
rational number is they're telling us
these numbers are rational so i can
express them as these type of ratios so
what is a over b going to be a over b
is going to be m over n
over
p
over q
which is equal to m over n if i divide
by a fraction it's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal
q
over p
let me write that a little bit
q
over p
which is equal to m q
over n p
well mq is going to be an integer if the
product of two integers is going to be
an integer and np is going to be another
integer the product of two integers is
an integer so i've just said i've just
shown that a
a over b can be expressed as the ratio
of two integers so a over b is for sure
in fact i've just proven it to you a
over b is for sure going to be
rational let's do a few more of these
this is interesting
all right
so now we're saying let a and b be
irrational numbers is a over b
let a and b be irrational numbers is a
over b rational or or irrational and
like always pause the video and try to
think this through and you might want to
do some examples of some irrational
numbers and see if you can get when you
divide them you can get rational or
irrational numbers
well let's just imagine a world where
let's say that a is equal to
i don't know two square roots of two
and b is equal to the square root of 2.
well in that world a over b
a over b would be 2 square roots of 2
over the square root of 2 which would be
2 which is very much a rational number i
can express that as a ratio of integers
i could write that as 2 over 1 and
there's actually an infinite number of
ways i can express that as a ratio of
two integers so in this case i was able
to get a a over b to be rational based
on a and b being irrational
but what if
what if instead of what if a was equal
to the square root of 2
and b
is equal to the square root of
let's say b is equal to the square root
of 7. well then a over b
would be equal to the square root of 2
over the square root of 7
which is still going to be irrational i
mean another way to think about it i'm
not proving it here but you can think
about this is going to be the square
root of two
sevenths so we have something that's not
a perfect square under the radical so
we're going to end up with an irrational
number so
we can we could show one example where a
over b is rational and we showed one
example where it is irrational so it can
be either way
either way let's do a few more of these
all right
let a be a non-zero rational number is a
times square root of 8 rational or
irrational
well the key here is if you multiply
an irrational number and why is this an
irrational number
it has a perfect square in it but it's
not a perfect square in and of itself
square root of 8 is square root of 8 is
equal to the square root of 4 times 2
which is equal to the square root of 4
times square root of 2 which is equal to
2 square roots of 2.
and this is kind of getting to the punch
line of this problem but if i'm if i
multiply a rational times an irrational
i am going to get an irrational so
square root of 8 is an irrational and if
i multiply that times a rational number
i'm still going to get an irrational
number so this is going to be for sure
irrational
let's do one more of these
so we're told let a be an irrational
number is negative 24 plus a rational or
or irrational and i won't give i won't
give a formal proof here but it'll give
you more of an intuitive feel it's it's
nice to just try out some numbers and i
encourage you to pause the video and try
to think through it yourself
let's just imagine some some values
imagine if we a a is irrational a is
irrational so what if a
was equal to negative
pi which is approximately equal to
negative
3.14159 and it keeps going on and on
forever never never never repeating
well then
then we would have negative 24
plus a would be equal to negative 24
minus pi
which would be approximately negative
27.14159 the decimal expansion
everything to the right of the decimal
is going to be the exact same thing as
pi
so this looks like at least for this
example is going to be
irrational and let's see if a was square
root of 2 negative 24
plus the square root of 2
well once again
i'm not doing a proof here but
intuitively you know this is going to be
a this is going to be a decimal it's
going to have a decimal expansion that's
going to go on forever never repeat and
so this would just change what's to the
left of the decimal but
not really change what's well it will
change what's to the right of the
decimal because this is negative but
it's still going to go on forever and
never repeat and if in fact this was
if this was this way
then to the right of the decimal you
would have the same thing as the square
root of 2 to the left of the decimal you
would just have a different value you
would have what negative negative 25
point whatever whatever whatever and so
this is when you add a rational number
to an irrational number we prove it in
other videos a rational plus an
irrational is going to be irrational
irrational if you want that proof we
have other videos within this tutorial